as a fan of most things vampire like
real vampire that don't Sparkle I bring
you this Tru Blood are so when true
blood first came out I didn't watch it
not for the first couple seasons
Twilight romance [ __ ] was everywhere
sells like alright true Bloods like
Twilight with tits but then I watched
the show now I'm gonna let you know
right off the bat this is not the
Twilight craze cash out I thought it
would be before I saw the show yeah the
main characters of the story are a
vampire named Bill and a waitress named
Sookie played by rogue from x-men who
are dating the dating aspect is a big
part of the show but it's not the point
of the show like with Twilight the whole
thing is like oh I think it has sex it
doesn't make love and True Blood they
bang a Mike episode 3 so they are dating
but shows always involve people who are
dating [ __ ] the Dark Knight had a love
triangle doesn't mean it's like Twilight
see what I mean it's now getting that
out of the way let's get to the show the
show is actually really good long story
short two years ago vampires came out of
the coffin is what they call it they
came out and said hey we're actually
real so integrate us into your society
so vampires and humans can exist like a
bunch of step kids who were living under
one roof we can't stand each other it's
pretty much it and they were able to
come out and tell everyone that they
exist because they fed on humans form
you know as long as vampires were ever
around thousands of years but this
company in Japan devised a drink called
True Blood hence the name of the show
that's a substitute for actual blood it
gives them all the nutrition they need
how we all live in harmony problem is a
lot of vampires hate the taste of the
[ __ ] so unless you're a vampire who's
gone more mainstream than mmm you want
you some human blood so the vampires are
integrated into our society so they have
to abide by our rules but first and
foremost they enforce their rules among
themselves like for example if you're a
vampire you cannot kill another vampire
for a human being ever I get the
distinct feeling that if you're a
vampire and you see another vampire
about to Club mother Teresa like a baby
seal and you kill that vampire to save
her you're in deep [ __ ] the show
incorporates a lot of supernatural
things aren't just limited to vampires
like the vampires they're not like
scientific vampires it's not like blade
were they're like oh yeah they're
vampires they need to feed because their
bodies don't sustain hemoglobin or
whatever like in the first or second
episode Bill and Sookie you're talking
to so he's like how are you alive Bill's
like magic I don't know so once they
establish that in the show they're free
to do a lot of magic type things and
they do and I think they do it well and
what I also like this bill like the main
vampires Dayton rogue from x-men he's
actually not all warm and fuzzy I mean
yeah he's really proper he's all like
shooked do not
that but he's actually done some dark
[ __ ] even now he's like killed people I
mean the likable characters are really
likable but they're kind of damaged and
that makes the characters more real
believable and relatable I like that
Lafayette's like the best character in
the show Vegas flaming gay dude I've
ever seen on the small screen one of the
coolest characters also you can be the
biggest homophobic redneck ever and
you'll be like you know I don't care
what anyone says like they're Lafayette
he's my bro most sexual dad touchin
dicks but all in all the show is really
badass it's really bloody when it wants
to be bloody it's intriguing it's funny
and the intro to the show is like really
dirty yet awesome so seasons 1 & 2 are
out on DVD right now season 3 is coming
out at the end of this month I think the
30th I think so I'd say check it out
it's not for everybody I do recognize
that if you don't like blood and its
really violating to you when vampires
fry in the Sun light rather than Sparkle
you might want to skip on True Blood but
if you're a fan of like old-school
vampire lore check it out you'll
probably like it cuz it does old vampire
lore in a modern day really well - have
you seen True Blood if you have who's
your favorite character comment below
let me know I want to know mine Eric
Northman dude it's probably a very
common answer but I don't give a [ __ ]
he's the sheriff of the territory he
runs a bar called Fangtasia and he threw
Lady gaga over a balcony dudes a badass
and if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
that's right red white and Wi-Fi yeah
uh-huh